[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic welcome
everybody to
this edition of pandemic podcasts
with your fearful host dr brian keating
as i am known
but i'm talking today with a man who
became a digital friend i met him i
followed him
17 years ago i first learned about
today's guest
and over the years my admiration has
only improved
for he is the man i consider the most
interesting man in the multiverse and
that is none other than
philip greenspun joining us today from
taxachusetts where it's my second
conversation from
massachusetts today i had a conversation
with your neighbor
professor max tegmark at mit your alma
mater
how are you doing today phillip very
well but uh we now refer to it as
massachusetts not taxatives
ah well better here than there or there
than here we have uh
i just feel emasculated but that's the
only reason i'm doing all these podcasts
because
it's the one you know kosher reason you
cannot wear a mask
besides eating when you're on an
airplane and we will talk about
airplanes because that
is the mode the vector that i came to
know about your existence in
2015 and 20 2004 rather
i started to get interested rekindle my
love of aviation which had kind of
laid fallow for some time because of the
rigors of academia trying to get a a
post-doctoral position after going to
graduate school
and then going to get a postdoctoral job
at stanford where i was promptly fired
as i recounted my book as phil knows he
was one of my beta readers or early
readers of the book
but but ultimately i ran out of time
and then luckily i did get back into it
and phil deserves
a great deal of credit for it because
there's a brief window of time between
getting
a permanent academic track job as i have
now
and having kids which utterly destroys
all semblance of time and space so phil
first of all thank you for rekindling my
love of aviation and my connection to it
and really being kind of the person that
i aspired to
so let me read your uh your bio this is
from wikipedia
which is uh which is you know the source
of all scientific wisdom
so before you do that i i was uh i was
asked
i was being deposed by an attorney in a
matter where i was in a patent case
where i was an expert witness
and he pulled out the wikipedia page and
said um
did you write this yourself and i say
just
and i responded does does it say that
philip greenspun is the greatest human
being ever to walk the face of the earth
because if not then i didn't write it
that's right i always say like um you
know i i write i wrote the first draft
of my wikipedia
uh entry and then my mother-in-law wrote
the rebuttal
phil you do so many things and i want to
get into all of them but let me just
you know use the cliff notes my project
in 2021 is to take
all of wikipedia and condense it to you
know single sentences but
for you you were born in bethesda
maryland and you received a
scientific bachelor's degree in
mathematics from mit
in 1982 which meant that you were
about 19 years old when you got your uh
your bachelor's degree after you
graduated you worked for hewlett-packard
according here
you wrote papers on the one of the
earliest implementations of a medical
record system using the world wide web
and that was later used in uh in in
applications at harvard medical school
you worked at hearst corporation
you co-founded ours digita in 1997
uh and it's a company that grew to over
20 million in annual revenues by
the year 2000 earlier than that you
started
a company which i knew well although i
never put two and two together until
much later
that the same phil was responsible for
photo.net
uh which was a huge uh a huge leap
forward in photo sharing but also in
kind of this notion of of communities
online in some ways it was a
precursor to like reddit and things at
least in my mind it is i think
you might correct me for my stupidity
there
and then you got into aviation i believe
you got in
around the turn of the millennium maybe
a little bit before
and you quickly graduated up the ranks
to get almost every possible
rating including helicopters as well as
instructor ratings
and uh and you ended up writing a book
called travels with samantha maybe we'll
get into
that and i also think of you as a
teacher
you teach at mit you teach courses at
mit and
and other places you teach aviation as
well
but i want to ask you phil if one of
these intelligent aliens comes to earth
wakes you up in the middle of the night
shakes you and says who the hell are you
how do you identify yourself
well helicopter instructor is usually
my opening line if it's there if there's
a gathering of people because
computer programmer is usually a
conversation ender
um and uh but i do like to be known for
teaching
so uh yeah teaching helicopters although
i also teach airplane
instrument students and tech pilots is
uh is a better uh opener because it's
more unusual and it doesn't drive people
away there's
um i think it was at a talk of you
yours in new york a lot of people showed
up to hear about physics
and at the end of your talk i said if i
offered
uh each of these people the difference
between physics and engineering
is is if we offered these people a
hundred dollars
to stay for an extra 15 minutes and hear
a lecture on how their smartphone or
television worked
they would flee uh to every possible
exit
i just had on uh andy viturbi who is a
well-known mit alum as well uh
co-inventor
of cdma technology and and uh really
before that i had on
barry barris who won the 2017 nobel
prize
for co-detecting gravitational waves
from black holes crashing together a
billion years ago in our distant reach
of our galaxy or maybe another galaxy
rather
and both of them talked about how
how sad it is that so many people use
technology invented by engineers and
have no idea of the underlying
scientific
mechanisms by which these things operate
electromagnetic waves etc
and and so i i think it's um it's
interesting i'd like to get your
reaction
when when you encounter people that have
maybe a disdain of things like if you
tell them databases
uh but uh you know they might roll their
eyes even more but
um you know kind of why do you think it
is that that
so many people use this technology but
have no inclination no curiosity maybe
to find out
more about the physics or the underlying
mathematics of of how it actually works
i think the problem is you know that
engineering is
not taught in public schools you know
nobody
uh grows up with engineering except i
think james cameron the
director movie director has started his
own
school somewhere in the la area
where engineering is used but people
don't understand
you know how interesting it is to take a
problem
and come up with you know alternative
solutions to that problem and finally
come up with something that's
practical to build so they just can't
appreciate
since they never try to do it uh
you know they can't appreciate the
activity
when you co-founded rs digita
you also started a non-profit that
established a prize
which is you know second in prestige
only to the nobel prize and that's the
rs digital prize it's an award for young
web developers is that still going on
it's not still going on we also did a
university you know we had people we had
a lot of
um people with strong academic
backgrounds at our little
software company we thought well look as
long as we've got
uh you know a bunch of people who
you know have phds in computer science
and would be qualified to teach
this material and there's a big shortage
right now
of software developers and there's a lot
of people who want to get in on this
so we came up with a one-year
post-baccalaureate program
uh where we would teach we decided we
were not going to innovate on
the curriculum we would just teach the
standard mit stanford carnegie mellon
courses but we innovated on schedule
so they would learn it one course at a
time a month at a time
and we would innovate on environment so
instead of saying
the people who are the most diligent
about avoiding distractions
they'll do the best we said everybody's
going to come together
in a uh
you know open office type environment
and they just have to show up from nine
to six and pay attention
and if they have a question they can ask
the person
at the next desk or if that doesn't work
they can ask a teaching assistant who's
roaming around the room and it was
highly effectively took about 35
people who had you know poetry uh
backgrounds um and other non-technical
backgrounds
and we all got them they got them all
the way through
uh you know what a bachelor's in
computer science would entail
and they all got jobs it was really uh
that was that was probably the best
non-profit activity that i've done yeah
and it certainly had
uh kind of captivated maybe pre was a
precursor
to some of these endeavors i'm going to
have michael's sailor do you know who
that is
yeah i've heard of him he's an mit grad
as well
a lot of stuff coming out of mit uh he
is the
chairman of microstrategy corporation
which made headlines recently for
trying to convince uh elon musk to put
much of the
cash on hand on their balance sheet into
bitcoin
and so he's a huge advocate of bitcoin i
don't know have you
investigated bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
at all do you think that that has
the potential as some say to be you know
the
the improvement of the web whether it be
in terms of financial engineering
or in terms of you know security uh
does bitcoin or or blockchain rather
play any role in your life or in your
mental uh
way of cutting i mean i'm i'm
embarrassed to say that you know
i didn't catch the bitcoin wave early on
i did when i started teaching at harvard
medical school
you can see this on philip.greenspun.com
it's still there
just to uh to alienate people at harvard
medical school i created a web page
where you could if you're a doctor you
could type in the year that you
started medical school how much tuition
that you paid
and it would calculate um how much uh
you would be worth
if you had instead put your med school
tuition into bitcoin
and of course it was in you know in the
trillions of dollars in some cases
so that's my main involvement with
bitcoin you know i never really got it
it always seemed like something that was
going to be mostly useful for uh evading
taxation or you know paying off uh
people in criminal activities um
and then you know it really uh became
kind of uninteresting as a currency
replacement when
uh i saw that the transaction costs
going up you know now
i i forgot what i don't know how much it
cost now it may be over a hundred
dollars
to record in the blockchain
uh that you bought something so you know
if you try
bitcoin to buy a cup of coffee
you know that would have to be at least
100 and
you know four dollar coffee to pay for
these transaction costs and you don't
even know if the transaction will commit
you have to put it in there this is the
dirty secret of bitcoin
you can't be sure whether you've
actually
paid in the sense that it's recorded in
the blockchain
because if you don't add enough of a fee
for all the miners to put you into the
blockchain they'll just ignore the
transaction and say look this guy is
only
offering to pay us 20 and it'll cost us
more than that so we're going to ignore
it so
you know i i'm not that high on bitcoin
as a
as a real currency a function of bitcoin
i think
is uh helping people who want to um
you know leave the united states and not
pay u.s taxes actually i know some
people
who are sitting on you know tens of
millions of dollars
of profits in bitcoin and the government
has no idea that these people are rich
you know their wealth is on a post-it
note it's the private key to their
bitcoin
so if you think about it um should they
cash out their bitcoin and tell
california yes oh i made all this money
here's your 13
tell the federal government i made all
this money i mean joe biden
and president harris you know they're
talking about uh
40 capital gains rates should should
they give
more than half their profits or should
they just
you know quietly uh move
to you know a low tax country and uh
pay the u.s exit tax when they leave um
on the assets that
the government knows about uh carry
their post-it with them
with the bitcoin number and then cash in
once they're uh
in you know singapore or
uh united kingdom or some other place
with a lower taxes
that's my plan is to retire wealthy on
my
you know tenth of a bitcoin uh but you
know one of the
things that surprised me about you
saying that is that i see
naively you know blockchain as the
ultimate expression of the database
and you really convinced me a long time
ago
i used to think database is really
boring and it's just oh my god
i remember even making a database in
1989 for my
computer science course at case western
and pascal
which i don't even know if you could
like program in pascal nowadays
there must be some like very high level
interpreter of pascal but anyway i did a
database for some
project and i remember thinking oh this
is cool now i could you know use it to
keep track of my lemonade stands you
know profit and loss and inventory
but you know then i went on to other
things like the high profit world of
experimental astrophysics but but you
then later you know really convinced me
through your work and
and through discussions that we've had
that the database is almost like
the most essential aspect of human life
and
even the world wide web and that's why
i'm surprised to hear you say that about
blockchain because blockchain is kind of
like
as i understand it this open database of
every transaction
preserved in digital amber you know for
everybody to see
everybody to validate and one of the
things certainly it is used for
illicit activities maybe laundering or
whatever but
one of the promises of it like all
technology you know has
has limitations all financial technology
has limitations and
is built on the fundamental assertion
that i don't trust you
and we want to have some way of trusting
each other but one of the things that
appeals to me
is the ability to have a currency that
actually does
computation in that you can use it as a
store of
information not only of a store of
wealth so
maybe how do you react to that like the
notion of these smart contracts that can
be used in certain platforms
like ether um and other
you know blockchain based currencies is
there any not interest from you i'm
surprised that
you're so negative about it i think it
could be interesting but i mean
you know americans already speaking from
a parochial american point of view
you know for example if you go over to a
lot of european countries
and you want to know you know who has
title to a piece of land
uh you just go down to the city hall and
there's a record and whatever records
they have in the city hall
are dispositive there's no title
insurance
people would be confused by the concept
of having an
argument about who owns something
because you know
the city hall's records are considered
to be
the last word so even
you know blockchain i guess it's useful
if you don't have some kind of central
authority that everybody can trust
um but
uh in the u.s even when we've had these
central authorities that people
you know do trust like you know you can
trust
the government wants to collect property
tax so we should be able to
trust them regarding who owns property
but we're still not willing
to do it um so i don't know if they
really i think what americans would need
to make
better use of databases you know is more
of a
change in attitude rather than an
enhancement in technology
europeans were doing this when the
technology was you know
just pencil and paper right
yes and even you know maybe even more
primitive
than that i want to talk about some of
the work that you've done
um again sort of database
related in some sense photo.net
you know is kind of a repository um
you know photographers and and tips and
as i said it's kind of like a reddit
subreddit just for like like the ultra
you know
interested photographers but can you
talk about that how did photo.net come
about
and why was it so successful in your
opinion
you know i think um i think it was
successful because
it was early you know there was not much
else on the internet if you wanted to
learn about photography
so um you know people say well how do
you
how do you do today how would one do
today what you did in 1993
and the answer is you know you can't do
it because there's
too much competition for people said
time energy
and attention um but photo.net it
started out
you know i was really passionate about
the world wide web
uh and i said this is going to be
everything your your spreadsheet's going
to be
in the browser your word processor is
going to be in the browser
you're going to be working cooperatively
with other people through the browser
there's going to be no more desktop
applications
you know i was saying all these things
in early 1993
uh around the hallways of mit and
everybody told me to shut up
professors said i was an idiot uh in
some sense they were right you know i'm
i'm still paying for microsoft office
today
so the desktop application uh hasn't
gone away
um but so i took the summer off
since nobody wanted to listen to me or
fund me and
i drove to alaska and back wrote up
travels with samantha
as a series of uh emails back to all my
friends
once a week and then when i got home
you know i had a slide show for all my
friends but for my friends
we didn't live in boston i thought well
i'll put up a webpage with the pictures
from the slideshow
and the text from these letters i've
been sending out
um and that uh
yielded all these questions people kept
asking questions about how did you take
the picture of those bears
how did you uh get the uh
you know uh sunset picture you know what
was your exposure time
so i thought well i'll just answer their
questions by writing a couple tutorials
on how to take pictures and then they
won't have to email me anymore
but of course the more i wrote the more
questions
were raised because it's an open-ended
topic
then i built a discussion forum uh this
is you know late 1993 early 1994 i guess
uh and i said well people can post their
questions and then i'll answer them and
then people will see the exchange
and of course that ended up growing into
a community where
you know one one reader would ask a
question
and then another reader would answer it
and i wouldn't have to be involved
so that led to a big you know tool kit
of software
for photo.net that i was giving away
free to anybody else who wanted it
and wanted to build a community maybe on
a different topic
[Music]
so a bunch of big companies
called me saying we wanted to use this
for you know internal systems
or public-facing websites and you know
hung up probably on the first
five customers i said hey you've got how
many people you got in your i.t
department and they would say you know
2 000. i'd say i give you the source
code i gave you it's documented
you got 2 000 programmers you know and
you want
you know these six new features in the
software why don't you build it yourself
you know slam the phone down
but after uh about six of those i
thought well maybe there's a business
here you know
they're they're offering to pay money to
add these features to the toolkit and
that was the
genesis of ours digital where we did
what's now pretty common support and
service
at a fee for what is free and open
source
software and you know that was pretty
successful although
of course today everything's on a larger
scale so
uh you know it's almost an embarrassment
to say we had
a profitable 20 million a year revenue
company that's
uh yeah facebook standards that's
slappable
but as i said i think it was you know
kind of the origin of a lot of these
quora and reddit and sort of uh
certainly had that dna as a long early
early precursor to those
to those sites um and and that way you
are very prescient
i'm just looking now on my amazon you
know search history purchase history
so i purchased um travels with samantha
now the first time i purchased it was
april 18 2010 so that was 10 years ago
it was written
in july 2000 so
um or at least the amazon version that i
have is
the heart yeah the hard copy is from
around then but it was written
in 1993 yeah i mean i guess what what
really distinguished me from
uh you know my friends who built
amazon.com you know i was building
database backed
electronic commerce sites that launched
right around the same time as amazon
you know what was different is that i
wanted to
teach other people how to do it whereas
the other working
software engineers you know either
didn't have the time or didn't have the
interest
so you know i think i can take credit
for
uh a lot of people came to the
conclusion at the same time that the
relational database management system
would be a great tool for managing the
concurrency problem of
having you know hundreds or thousands of
users simultaneously
trying to update a database uh by
placing an order or adding a comment
or bidding on something in ebay or
whatever
but what i did that was different was
you know i wrote it up as a textbook
basically for
uh new programmers and uh you know then
created a course at mit where
you know anybody could learn and we made
all the materials
for the mit course available to other
universities
so i think you know that's um i i don't
want to say that i came up with this
uh architecture that became conventional
of the relational database management
system behind a website
uh but i did uh i did
write the uh the textbooks that
uh you know enabled and a generation of
programmers
to uh easily uh adopt that architecture
now i might be wrong but uh you
introduced me to another
mit uh very popular podcaster
matt as a goofin
guthmiller yeah so he has a great
youtube channel about flying around the
world in his bonanza and he was one of
the youngest if not the youngest to
circumnavigate the globe and of course
we have a
mutual friend robert de laurentis who's
been to the polls
both poles over both poles at least in
an airplane and and you of course helped
advise him advise me about that
particular voyage he's
gone around horizontally and vertically
i want to switch now to aviation but
before i do
maybe it was matt who told me that
basically you invented
click to pay and things like amazon uses
but you didn't patent it for some reason
um can you talk about that what what is
the role of kind of
you phil greenspun in and e-commerce
and why would you not you know kind of
lock in
the you know potential profits from such
a patent
of intellectual property sure
i can talk about that but uh i will say
the first time i heard about matt guf
miller
but i hadn't met until after he'd done
his round-the-world
flight where he was the youngest person
ever to fly around the world
uh and he did it in a single engine
beachtrap bonanza which
requires a level of bravery that
is impossible to communicate to a
society where people are afraid to leave
their house now or
send their children to school he
launched
with extra fuel tanks over the pacific
ocean for
a 16-hour leg lying on one propeller in
one piston engine
but anyway i was giving a talk at mit on
a fun talk on helicopter
games that's the kind of fun talk you
can have at mit
and uh matt uh
you know towards towards the middle of
the talk or towards the end of the talk
matt introduced himself and identified
himself and i
i told the assembled uh listeners i said
oh you guys you shouldn't be listening
to me at all you know here's
here's matt guf miller you know he
should be the one talking not me
um he's much more interesting so uh
the question was um well
oh yeah why not patent the stuff i don't
know you know i was busy
first of all so you know and also people
people kept telling me how bad my ideas
were you know i was working at horst
corporation
and at mit press i also helped mit press
build their online site
i think i implemented one click ordering
for mit press
um and they liked it reasonably well so
they kept running it
oh wow you know at hearst things that we
now take for granted and say that's a
great idea
at hearst corporation they owned all
these newspapers which had classified
ads
so i said look um
what about a system where when people
place an ad
it also goes into a website database
a centralized nationwide one and because
people might
be buying things from across the country
we'll need a reputation system
where if you buy from somebody and you
have a good experience you can
rate them and we should have since it's
on a computer we can let people either
sell it for a fixed price or auction it
there's basically every feature of ebay
um built right around the same time as
he bought in ebay in 1995
and i told the hearst managers um you
know
about it and they said you know that's a
terrible idea um
so i said look i've already written the
software do you want to see it
and i would you know maybe that could
get their attention for five minutes to
look at it and they said
it's still a terrible idea i said well
can i take the software and run it on
myphoto.net site so people can buy and
sell cameras
like that's such a bad idea that
software is worthless and
you can do whatever you want with it i
put it on my photo.net site
um so that that's the that's probably
the main reason i i don't want to say
that i was so altruistic
i mean i kind of was i was giving away
all my software for free
um but it wasn't that
uh i thought uh you know i'm giving up
the opportunity to become incredibly
rich as a patent
owner um i asked that of
andy viterby also the co-founder of
qualcomm
and inventor of the viterbi algorithm
and you know why didn't they patent it
you know early on
uh you know because they had these huge
government contracts for
uh and they also had contracts with like
hbo because people were
stealing their signals from satellite
dishes and so you know part of it was
like
anti-piracy led to the creation of this
tool that improves the bandwidth of cell
phone cdma technology
and he said he made the point that by
the time the patents
actually would have started you know
reaping
you know remuneration that many decades
had gone by and they weren't or
they would have expired and certainly
you know amazon that's not the case if
the f
or ebay if that's the case but this
theme of like
you because i view you as a person with
great conviction and courage
and it's sort of surprising at least
before i knew you
that you didn't have the courage of your
convictions or you weren't
like willing to listen and say look i
think it's a good idea i don't care what
some
hearst magazine dinosaur you know
newspaper thinks about what my idea
is i'm going to go ahead i'm going to do
it and yeah you don't have to do it to
make money you could do it to buy a
fleet of airplanes to teach
you know under you know privileged kids
but
what what have you changed in that way
you know if you if you
uh do things nowadays would you be less
inclined to listen to what some
so-called expert has to say about it
well it's not just that i mean remember
to patent you to patent something and
have a legitimate patent you truly have
to be
first and there's just not that much new
under the sun if you'd asked me
when i was developing that classified ad
system has anyone else ever built this
i would have said you know no nope this
is you know it was my idea
nobody else has built it i had the idea
because i was working at hearst which
had a big
classified ad business to begin with but
you know unbeknownst to me
you know ebay was developing at roughly
the same
time so and and probably there was
somebody even before ebay you know that
i don't know about
so uh i'm not convinced that i was
you know i was definitely an early
person in this area but
even catalog shopping you know all the
stuff that's on the web today
was done with modems by peapod the
grocery delivery company they were they
were doing
uh you know catalog shopping e-commerce
which some people did eventually managed
to patent
but i don't think the patents um some of
them were
ultimately invalidated and probably most
of them
uh that were really just on that concept
should have been invalidated
because uh the fact that it was on the
web wasn't materially different
from having it in the dos application
you know modem again to your local
grocery store
right so looking at philip greenspun
philip.greenspun.com
i am of course you know familiar with
many of your activities
uh there are four super categories
aviation photography travel and teaching
we talked a little bit about teaching i
talked a little bit about travel and
photography
let's talk about aviation what you know
i remember hearing
uh from john and martha king san diego
heroes about a very simple definition
of why people should become pilots and
their
their statement was once you learn to
fly once you even
get your do your first solo where you're
alone in an airplane
for the first time that your identity
is forever changed that you are now a
pilot
and you know we're not all chuck yeager
despite the way we might want to talk to
air traffic control
but um what is it about aviation that uh
that you know transfixes you personally
what what drew you to it and what
continues to
keep you held under its gravitational uh
force as opposed to lift thrust and drag
well i'm definitely not uh chuck yeager
because
my most memorable conversation with air
traffic control was
with new york approach where i got in
between them vectoring air buses up to
uh europe
i got them to call my mom in maryland to
tell her that i was
encountering headwinds and was going to
be half an hour late to land at the
gaithersburg maryland airport simpler
times so yes that's uh
that's the difference between me and
chuck yeager um
but uh you know what i i wouldn't i
wouldn't
uh i would my perspective is a little
different than the kings
you know i fell in love with aviation
because i like being up in the air
looking at the earth from above
so that was the thing that drew me in in
the first place
but what i think is great about aviation
is it's a
combination of physical skills
intellectual skills planning ahead um
and emotional skills because if you're
not afraid when you're up in the air
then you're probably uh you know
somehow defective you know you should be
afraid
uh when you're up in the sky it's not a
natural thing for
an animal other than a bird
so the question is can you behave
rationally
even when you are afraid and for most
people
the answer is no uh actually
corona panic is a perfect example of
that you know
people are afraid of a new virus
which does make sense but then their
reaction is completely irrational
and they they you know tune out
all possible rational pathways
in favor of uh stuff that doesn't really
make them safer
um but you know will potentially
harm them in a lot of other ways so in
aviation
however you learn you know if you're
approaching the runway
i used to fly the canada regional jet
one of my fun jobs was working for delta
airlines so we would fly the
canada regional jet and the final
approach speed is 145 knots so you're
going 170 miles an hour
pointed down it doesn't have leading
edge slats like a boeing
or an airbus it's an adapted business
jet so the only way to
maintain enough air speed to keep the 50
000 or 47 000 pounds for landing
uh weight airplane uh flying at an
adequate airspeed is to point the nose
down towards the ground like a lawn dart
and if you're approaching the ground 170
70 miles an hour you know you should be
scared
and in fact there was a special briefing
card for jump seating
you know mainline your airplane pilots
because so many of them they've gotten
into the cockpit
the jump seat and they're used to flying
boeing's
and they would freak out and start
screaming uh
you know to pull up pull up um because
they didn't uh
they weren't familiar with the camera
regional jet so anyway
uh that is what's great about aviation
you know you
are part of you is going to be scared
for on every landing
um you're approaching the runway it
doesn't feel right
uh helicopters actually in some ways are
a little bit less scary because you just
slow down
you gradually slow down you know i for
for people who say they're afraid of
aircraft
i often will take them up first in the
helicopter rather than
an airplane because you don't have that
you know
rushing off the runway sensation and you
don't have that hurtling towards the
ground sensation
so that's what i love about aviation it
works your emotional brain your
intellectual brain and your physical
muscles your coordination all at the
same time
and and it feels good when you can do
it's hard to do a perfect flight but
it feels great when you can do you know
any kind of successful flight
yeah any you know major accident scene
you can walk away from as they say
i remember reading you know before i
even had the temerity to contact you
using email i remember reading and being
really
uh swayed by this argument that you made
for certain types of people
you go to college and you get good
grades
and but but you know after that you can
go to graduate school which is
not exactly like super college i mean i
always say
college there's homework problems and
they all have solutions you may not be
smart enough to solve them
not you personally phil but uh but other
people may not be but there is a
solution that someone smart enough can
answer
in grad school you have super problems
that even
your advisor he or she doesn't know if
there's a solution because there may not
be a solution to it
and then after that you're like a
post-doc or professor whatever
there's no more grading like then you're
done uh unless you go for the nobel
prize you know in my case
or or you write a book or you become you
know michio kaku
and lawrence krauss and start thinking
about wormholes and the mind of
god but uh but getting back to this
hierarchical kind of um hurdle
that academics fight with and then we
kind of lose track we've been graded for
30 years and now we're not graded
anymore but aviation
offers this unlimited set of challenges
you pointed out
a long time ago in a blog post that was
kind of like a throwaway line but in
many ways it really spoke to me because
you're basically saying like the faa
sets up all these different things you
can challenge yourself on your web page
you haven't updated it lately but you go
over your milestones
in aviation starting with um exactly
uh 19 years ago last last week or so you
had your first lesson in 2001
december 11 not september 11 working
your way all the way up to being an
airline pilot
helicopter instructor flying across the
country north south east and west
and then it turns right now terminates
with completing uh training in a pilates
pc12 which is a
very very large um challenging aircraft
the single engine turbo prop
i know you've gotten a pilot or license
or pilot
type ratings and jets how come you
haven't updated your milestones yet
recently well that's a good point you
know
i don't have that many left there's
multi-engine seaplane which i should get
there's a good
instructor down in alabama or the
grumman widget
it would be fun but
uh you know now i'm just enjoying it you
know we did a trip a friend of mine
recently wanted to be dropped off and
bend oregon
yes into i think he'd flown commercial
uh a couple times recently and there's
been some sort of mask
altercation in either an airport or on
one leg
you know not involving him but it was
still unpleasant enough that he's like i
just want to be dropped off
bend oregon so you know we loaded the
whole family in the back of the flood
his family and ours uh dropped off some
people in chicago
went to uh mount rushmore in south
dakota
went to den this took the family back
via san francisco
las vegas mammoth cave in bowling green
kentucky and the corvette museum
stopped to see the grandparents and
outside their retirement home in to
maryland
and back to boston so it was an eleven
day trip and you know it felt great to
have gotten the family through this
whole thing to have
you know picked days and times when you
know they could be flown and they
wouldn't be subjected to
getting bumped around even though we
crossed over the mountains
um so to me you know those are still
uh good milestones i guess i should um i
should put in that i landed
i landed on the space shuttle runway
back in january
oh wow an aviation group and we were
invited by um
some astronauts who were part of the
same group to come visit them so
we landed on the shuttle runway uh that
was a lot of fun down in cape canaveral
very good yeah i had on jessica my ear i
interviewed her
at the beginning of january 2020 while
she was on the space station that was a
surprisingly not very long distance call
because she was floating overhead about
200 miles up
just interviewed and then i interviewed
one of her colleagues nicole stott who
flew on the shuttle twice
and they spoke about flying you know in
some ways while nicole did at least
that she was never scared for herself
but she was scared like what would
happen for her kids like
the trauma if something were to happen
to her as you know they lost you know
two percent of all shuttles in flight
uh or something like that uh two percent
you know compared to the number of
flights two flights ended a
complete loss of crew and and vehicle uh
but she worried about that and
um and you know i wonder do you ever
experience you know this kind of
nerd you talked about you know you
should be scared a little bit but you
know
but before you fly or consequences of
flying i mean
this question i i have you know get
often asked the cliche
what do you do when the engine quit
something uh even in a helicopter you
have to deal with that so
you do you deal with fear at all or have
you
you know so many so many hours so many
so much experience that you've become an
old pilot
and are no longer a bold pilot
i i do you know especially helicopter
instruction
um you know there's there's mistakes
that students can make that
are pretty challenging for the
instructor to fix it's not like an
airplane where
if you have altitude and a little bit of
air speed you're basically
can recover from almost any situation
you know that
the helicopter if you're doing
um you know practice auto rotations
almost all the accidents happen where
people are
you know preparing for real world
emergencies that may never arise
like that so you you use the throttle to
roll the engine off
to show people well look this is how
dangerous an engine failure could be
i've created this really dangerous
situation
you have to do it because it's part of
the uh the training
to know how to auto rotate and land the
helicopter without an engine but
uh so i do worry you know i try to cut
my risk
even though i have an airline transport
pilot certificate the same as a
united airlines captain you know i
really try if i can if i can
arrange my schedule so that the flight
is something that
would be doable by a student pilot then
i arrange it that way so i say look i'm
going to go to the big airport with the
long runway
i'm going to go in daylight hours if i
can um
i'm going to go in visual weather
conditions
um you know if that's at all reasonable
i'm going to
avoid icing conditions and super high
you know crosswinds and all that other
stuff so i just try to set it up
so that i never need to use my higher
level of skill
um especially like a blue angel pilot
won't say you know
people say wow you fly for the blue
angels you must have really good
hand-eye coordination it's like
no i i use my training to avoid needing
to have good handout coordination
um yeah so that's that that's exactly my
exactly my philosophy um
yes i recognize it as a risk and uh
you know statistically it is you know
higher risk for example than cove but
i'm constantly
being cautioned by every conversation
now that i have with people like stay
safe
stay healthy they're always telling me
this i'm like you know i
i i you know it wouldn't be a good
social convention to say look i'm a
helicopter instructor
and now that all forms of competing
recreation have been outlawed by the
governor
you know our flight school is actually
pretty busy so
know it is not my you know cope is a
risk but it's not my biggest risk
it's like you know coming finally i can
take a test where getting a negative
result gives me a lot of pleasure
um i want to close up with a couple
questions i'm going to ask you to ask
all my guests
on online but i want to talk just a
little bit more about your
you know kind of current uh
peregrinations shall we say
in the world of computing and uh
teaching at harvard university as you do
now
uh running a blog that you know your
your joke is you
have an interesting idea a posting every
day and an interesting idea every
few months today you've got one about
american central planners tackle vaccine
scarcity
uh you've been you've been talking a lot
about kovid
kova what do you call it corona panic uh
you talked a little bit before that
about the trump inferior
but what you know what are you really
most interested in
again you you do so many different
things you're so interesting
uh to be around to to fly with we've
flown together
you've given me my first helicopter
lesson what would you
you know what's kind of your dream day
like what what do you
uh what are you looking forward to and i
want to ask you about new year's
resolutions
if you indulge in such things but first
of all
take what does phil's ideal day look
like
i mean for me teaching is really what i
do love
um so at harvard med school for example
we have a big database of insurance
claims
and we start with third year medical
students they're very interesting
intelligent
uh nice people but um
you know they don't have any background
in software development usually
um you know in a class of 25 people we
might have
four that have significant programming
backgrounds um
so i just love showing them the power of
uh you know learning the sql language
and being able to pull
from these billions of medical records
interesting insights
and to you know what's the effect of
these different drugs how effective are
they really
how effective are the flu vaccines uh in
terms of
reducing the number of people who will
eventually file a claim
where the doctor says they had they had
the flu um
and learning some statistical
programming so i love that
uh i do like teaching at mit you know
the aeronautical engineering class or
the software classes that i taught there
for the same reasons so i think that's
that's where you know i experience
probably the most joy is working with
you know smart young people and helping
them uh
learn and there's the same thing with my
website you know i just try
to take everything that i've learned and
write it down
so that other people don't have to you
know spend the time that i spent
to study something uh the corona stuff
is a bit of a distraction but i think i
guess you know all of america has been
pretty distracted
by this so i just look for sort of
what's interesting to me is the
cognitive dissonance
so for example the post from today that
you mentioned
you know people are saying we need a
bigger government if we have a
bigger government all of our problems
will be solved the government will do
the stuff really well
but at the same time they're saying look
these state health departments and all
50 states are doing
you know terrible jobs at distributing
the coronavirus vaccine they're just
going to let it
expire in a refrigerator because they
can't figure out
you know how to get into people's arms
which
you know you can go the smallest village
anywhere on planet earth and you can buy
a coca-cola
so obviously the market has a way of
distributing uh
distributing stuff um
but um yeah i guess most of my ideas in
computing that would really help
people are a little bit too big they
involve you know starting a company
working 100 hours a week um
and i just don't know with you know i
have kids i don't know if it's fair to
them for me to go back to that but
like one of my ideas is people know how
to use their phones
and they're pretty good at that at the
same time people are terrible at using
their
desktop and laptop computers you know
i think you know physics professors
might be an exception
um but uh for the average person
it's very burdensome for them to have to
learn the macintosh operating system or
windows
when they already have a device that
they know how to use so
that's one of my pet ideas is you should
be able to have some kind of machine on
your desktop where you plug your phone
into the machine
and it gives you the illusion that
you're still using your phone so you
have all your computing services
available
but the interfaces software everything's
this looks the same as if you were still
on your phone
and uh but again that's the kind of
thing that a facebooker google could do
pretty easily
um they've just chosen not to um
you think that we have suffered because
of
you know kind of the proliferation of
software i compare software
to like theoretical physics where
there's you know literally
you know 200 different ideas for
theories of everything or wormholes or
time warps and stuff but there's like
five experiments that you know there's
one you know major
large hadron collider right so there's
no like
proliferation of experiments of
everything it's all theory
and i make this comparison that like
theory is cheaper
because you don't need as much to do it
you don't even need a computer to do it
i mean
most of the best you know work that you
might know from einstein was not done
using latex or you know obviously some
some fancy word processors so it was
pencil and paper
and you know we've got a lot but i
wonder you know is the
kind of exponential you know
proliferation of color
13 terabytes what was it like yesterday
it was but you know
10 terabytes or whatever data is getting
produced so massively and i wonder is
there any
hardware like are we lacking hardware
like the phone you just showed
i make the point you know at stanford
you can name like 10 apps
or software companies google being one
of them you know a youtube it came out
of
stanford directly in somewhat sense but
you know name a cell phone that came out
of it now mit is different because it is
it has a very forward-looking
kind of practical application you saw
boston dynamics robots you know flipping
around dancing
say do you love me uh but the question
is you know
what what about this proliferate are we
is humanity developing
so much code and so much data and not
enough hardware to take advantage of it
i mean the hardware yeah the hardware is
a little bit stalled right now right i
i've got a four-year-old pc i think and
i'm not motivated to
upgrade it because the new ones really
aren't any better
i think the biggest problem in computing
right now is
that you don't have learning built into
the software
as a default so for example
you can upload your pictures to your
desktop computer every day
and uh you know maybe you always pick up
certain pictures and move them into
folders with the conventional naming
scheme that you like
how you want to organize your photos you
know the computer will never learn
it'll never learn hey this is how brian
likes to organize his photos
i'll just you know ask uh is this what
you'd like me to do with these new
new pictures so sometimes you know if
everybody wants to do things a certain
way they'll
explicitly build that into the operating
system but the operating system can't
learn from you
it's starting to i mean when i get in my
car and i have a tesla and
it'll so you know drop the kids off at
uh
at the uh local prison no i mean at
their school
you know whatever uh so it's learning
certain things and my iphone you know
we'll know it's a holiday
you know tomorrow so it'll let me sleep
in you know past the crack of noon when
i normally
get up yeah yeah but look how bad
autocorrect is autocorrect
is really something that should learn
and it never
seems to do very well so that i think
shows you
the limits of learning you admitted to
being a microsoft you know
uh word user so so you you still have a
paper clip presumably you know asking
you what to do
yeah yeah i'm talking more about like
autocorrect typing on the iphone for
example
um so i think that's that's to me is the
limitation is that software isn't built
from day one with the idea that it's
going to
gradually uh learn and be trainable
because if you rely on human programmers
to sort of put in every
you know possible situation with if
statements it's never going to
to work the world is is too big and
complicated a place
to get you know disinformation and you
know like
we're sucking today with max tag mark
you know imagine if you know galileo
puts up uh you know he's in he's living
in today's era or twitter exists
in 1632 and you know the the earth goes
around the sun
and then like this information is
dispute this claim is disputed by the
catholic church
uh and it's really true if you go to
your iphone and you say
i want to know what um what the time is
in jerusalem
israel and you go there it's jerusalem
is the only city on earth that's not in
the country
you know that's an active decision like
somebody made the decision not to have
that
as a you know as an active choice and
you know so
in some ways maybe we better maybe be
worse the same professor at mit max
tegmark was talking about
ai artificial intelligence really going
to
the next level when it can write its own
code
so you seem to be um i don't know are
you
are you skeptical that ai will be able
to basically write itself
and let's ignore the you know the
singularity and the destruction of all
life
you know after that occurs but do you
see a future where code will just write
itself i mean already we can do
you know gpt-3 we can dump in you know i
always say like who would you rather
learn physics from me or
or albert einstein well albert einstein
wrote a lot of stuff down it's digitized
dump it in and you'll have you know
professor einstein
teaching you relativity instead of
professor keating so what do you make of
the
prospects and and promise of ai you know
if nothing else to write code
you know that outperforms itself well i
mean that's part of what i was talking
about right if the machine is trainable
then either it's written some new code
to reflect that training or it's got
some new data to reflect that training
so
i i think i'm agreeing um
i'm agreeing with professor tegmark um
however you know ai is it's a it's an
it's an industry
with a long history of over promising
um you know when it started they said
look it's a 20-year problem give us all
this money and we'll
give you an ai in 20 years and when that
didn't work they said look it's a
50-year problem
and it's still you know there's all
these people
mostly they don't have kids they say you
know
the singularity is near most humans
won't have jobs
and i say look uh
machines are so advanced that they've
rendered
humans redundant you know you go try to
find
try to hire a babysitter for less than
25 an hour
it will actually show up to your house
and then
come back i'd show up once with my kids
yeah and then come back and tell me
that you know there's this huge surplus
of human labor out there
you know because of machines so as of
right now
you know a human that will show up
and actually work um you know on the
schedule that you've agreed
and be reasonably responsible and do
something that you know doesn't require
special training like being a babysitter
uh it's harder than ever to hire
somebody to do that
and we're very we're deep into the
period of time when the ai enthusiasts
said that you know half or more humans
would just be
sitting on the beach while the robots
did their old job
um so i think maybe the ai
enthusiasts are right but they're
they're wrong about the timeline you
know it may not even happen
um for 50 or 100 more years
you know the brain is still vastly more
powerful than all this hardware due to
the
number of inner you know the not that
many uh gates
or transistors in your brain but they're
there's a lot of them
but but they're heavily interconnected
so you know they're not that fast
they're uh there's a lot of them and
they're heavily interconnected
yeah and that brings me maybe the last
point uh for
you know looking in the future uh before
we look into your personal future what
you're
looking forward to in 2021 but that's
like quantum computers
are very good or better than any
classical computer
at simulating the properties of quantum
computers and i kind of think you know
maybe that's what will happen with ai
it'll start to understand itself
um but you know as i was quipping in my
in my
uh professorial way today you know
perhaps
the you know the thing that we don't we
don't need more intelligence
no we need more wisdom so like can we
create artificial wisdom
because that's what i would really care
about so max tag mark again he's
i would love to you know be the
matchmaker matching you guys together
uh in 2021 but he has this new uh
feature this new web project called
improvethenews.org
and it's all about like synthesizing
the notion is that there's this overton
window of what's acceptable to
someone on the left and so someone on
the right and they used to overlap and
now they don't
and so he has this feature where you can
it's a news aggregator
and you can basically crank it all the
way left you know for noam chomsky
fellow mit professor who i had on my
show this year
uh you know you could crack it all the
way to the right ben shapiro who i had
on my show
this year and the question is you know
do you get something in the middle
like how did how does your cortisol
level react
when you know when now you can control
i'm getting
you know fox news versus msnbc or
or you know in new york times so that's
a fun project and it's kind of like
simulating or maybe to expose the biases
i felt like he should have rolled it out
in science first to show
you know just for scientific consensus
how tenuous it is
we're often told you know listen to the
scientists and like
i don't know a scientist who just like
listens to scientists do you i mean
like i i fight with scientists that's
part of what science is it's supposed to
be argumentative and adversarial and
and to say oh just listen to them i'm
fine listening to you if you're an
expert you know on quantum computing but
that doesn't mean you're going to be an
expert in epidemiology but nowadays
we're all epidemiologists right
i think the wisest thing about the media
so i know a russian immigrant
here in massachusetts and uh regarding
uh our neighbors who you know
listen to npr and read the new york
times she says the the difference
uh between growing up in um
russia uh and the people here
is in the soviet times
uh we we didn't believe the propaganda
right
so the actual uh they had two newspapers
one was called
um one was called news and i forgot how
you say that in
russian you could have cestia that was
yesterday and then the other one was
called pravda
which means truth and they used to joke
and there's no truth in
in the news and there's no news in the
truth and they would say things like you
know
in in in russia you know the future
uh the future is always known but the
past is always changing and i worry
about us
in these in these perilous times but i
want to close on a note of
of optimism maybe looking forward to the
future as you know
january is named after the roman god
janus that looks forwards and backwards
at both times
uh what are you looking forward to in
2021
maybe resolutions that you've made i
made a resolution to
to drop five pounds um which i did this
year i dropped five pounds from my
double chin to my stomach
but what i'd like to do is to actually
keep it off do you have any new year's
resolutions and what are you looking
forward to in 2021
uh that's a good question well my last
my my last new year's resolutions
crashed and burned um which was to
travel more you know i said look this is
what i really love
is traveling and seeing more new parts
of the world so
i signed up you know i accepted
invitations from all my friends around
the world
people that i had met i was going to go
to the glenborn opera
in 2020 with this uh lady she was in the
james bond movie on her majesty's secret
service
60s and uh i had the plans to go to the
stands uzbekistan
and turkmenistan etc with mit travel
alumni travel which i think has now been
disbanded
shut down i was going to go with you to
chile that's right
um that will happen i'm sure so i would
catch the next eclipse down there
someday i don't know my concerns are
kind of parochial actually i'm kind of
looking for something
for our kids um it would be interesting
maybe we'll have to start a school
so what we would like for our kids is
a school where they have reasonably
strong academics
a couple hours of physical activity
every day
which schools have really cut down on um
and um no political indoctrination
so at least here in massachusetts you
know the schools have become these
centers
where they spent a lot of time trying to
educate the kids about
uh you know black lives matter diversity
and inclusion which is absurd because
these are in these suburbs where people
have
paid you know multiple uh times the cost
in order to get away from diversity uh
and um so it'd be nice to have a school
that
is concentrated on the academic mission
rather than on this political mission
um it's not that we're besides really
it's not that i'm
worried that our kids will be
indoctrinated it's just that now that
the schools have this political mission
they've forgotten about academics
they're like well
as long as we can teach some diversity
and inclusion
and about you know all the elements of
the rainbow flag
it doesn't matter whether they uh you
know
learn to read and write most enterprises
are only good at one thing
if that so now that the school is a
political environment instead of an
academic one
the academics are truly terrible so
anyway that would be the kind of thing
that would be interesting
the schools that exist that have a lot
of physical activity
are mostly like these professional
sports academies
so they're great if you want your kid to
become a professional tennis player
but if you don't need five hours a day
of activity and training
and and or your kid is just not that
coordinated
uh there's nothing left so that that
that's one goal which is a pretty boring
one
um maybe i should get that multi-engine
c plane rating so i don't know
i don't have a uh i don't have a great
new year's
uh resolution yes i and it would be good
to get uh
i definitely uh it's not good having
more chins than uh the shanghai phone
book
oh god oh and that one that was an
old one that's a weird al yankovic
reference ladies and gentlemen okay last
couple of questions i want to ask you
if you've ever seen the movie 2001 a
space odyssey
you will surely recognize what's that i
uh oh i didn't understand the last uh
half hour
that's okay uh you have to uh this is
just gonna refer to the first 42 seconds
uh when these primates in the savannah
of ancient africa
come upon this mysterious monolith this
black
obelisk looking thing uh that is
really put there by some unseen menacing
maybe benevolent civilization
billions of years ago to be deciphered
when humankind is ready
to read the writing on such a such an
obelisk
uh mit alum richard feynman uh
kind of described what he would want to
put on such an object a billionaire time
capsule
and he called it uh he said if in some
cataclysm
all scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and one sentence passed on to
the next generation of creatures
which statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words
i won't tell you what he said but i want
to know what would you put
on a billion year long lasting time
capsule
probably probably maxwell's equations
you know if you think about it actually
you know americans americans somehow
believe that
that the us is the center of science and
no offense to you being an american
scientist but really
the stuff that we actually need and
depend on on a daily basis
is pretty much all coming from england
or europe
you know so if you want heat in your
house
uh light in your bedroom um
tv you know all the things that people
love
computing even you know people think of
computing as an american thing but
it was all developed in parallel over in
england um
so i think for me electricity and
understanding
a lot of other stuff can be kind of
worked out from intuition you know if
you watch a
coconut fall from a palm tree then
you'll probably
pick up the idea of gravity soon enough
um
but electricity and magnetism is
fundamental of everything that we love
and uh it's not intuitive so that that
that's um
that's what i worked on there is
maxwell's questions yeah and then the
update of them
which is more relevant in my daily life
are the yang mills equations
which govern you know subatomic nuclei
uh but that
is admittedly more of my persuasion but
those were
created uh many many decades ago uh so
the last question i want to ask you
hearkens to the name of this podcast
which is one of sir arthur c clarke's
famous three laws his first one being
when we open the show with red in his
voice any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
his second law will appeal to the
contrarian greenspun
which is for every expert there's an
equal and
opposite expert and the third
law is the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
so that's kind of the origin of the name
of this podcast the into the impossible
podcast
so i want to ask you what was very
mysterious
about life the universe and everything
to a 20 year old phillip
but as you matured and grew older
through your courage your convictions
etc
now is eminently doable because you went
in
to the impossible
advice to your former self
um i don't know if i have a good
technical one for that
um you know i do think
i i do think people overestimate what
they can know
i guess when i was 20 years old i was
probably more sure
about the things that i knew i mean as
you've seen from john i and eddie's
right
most published uh research findings are
false
you know even things that are supposedly
scientific
uh are actually um
you know should be doubted uh so i think
that's
i i see so much of this you know in
politics
around corona around corona plague
uh people express certainty about
uh something that they really shouldn't
be certain about so i think
as i've gotten older i become more
willing to believe and understand that
you know other people can have a
different perspective
it's uh equally valid to mine it may
reflect their personal
situation you know before we're talking
about
we were talking about this before you
know the the merits of lockdown
are going to seem very different to
somebody who lives in a 6 000 square
foot suburban house
compared to somebody who lives with four
other people in a two-bedroom apartment
in the middle of a city somewhere
but i think a lot of people lose sight
of that and they're just saying well
you know science proves that i'm right
uh but often
often what they're saying is you know
it's about something that's
it's well it's right for me so i'll just
extrapolate to the rest of humanity it
also has to be right for everybody else
right survivorship bias that comes into
play
well phil i want to uh thank you very
much for being an inspiration to me
and do i know millions of people around
the world who benefited from your
your curious mind in the best sense of
the word
and i can think of no one more fitting
to uh
hold the mantle of today's guest on the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
than the very imaginative doctor philip
greenspun he is a doctor he is not a
medical doctor but he does prescribe
medication on demand and his address is
no i'm just kidding
phil where can people find you online if
you have to steer
folks to a couple of your resources
where would you want them to go
first of all my brother's a real doctor
i said i have that right on my resume so
you can't call me dr greenspun
um and anybody else who who
introduces themselves this doctor is
that at risk of me saying
um i'm so glad that you're here because
um i need my fentanyl prescription
renewed
um but yes you can uh you can come to my
modestly
uh named website philip.greenspun.com
okay great and then you have a twitter
account which um
i'm still i'm a web dinosaur so i'm not
a twitter achiever like you
that's right well from all of us at the
microsoft paperclip
headquarters uh phil we're on the west
coast you're going to be cracking open
the
champagne before we do say hello to 2021
and i hope you have a safe a happy
productive flying career in 2021 i know
everything else will work out fine i'm
not gonna
tell you to stay sanitized because i
know you already are
and i really want to thank you it's so
much fun talking to you and hopefully
we'll make this a traditional comeback
every so often and you and i will will
speculate and ruminate on the news of
the universe so
thank you so much phil for going into
the impossible you're welcome
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you